Bengie hi hey how you doing how long you
been an interim with us I just started
about two weeks ago all right tell Robyn
myself and Fred in the audience what
happened to you because I wasn't
following all this but it sounded kind
of interesting okay it's it's kind of
freaky but I just I just started here
two weeks ago and it was just my third
day here I hadn't even seen Howard in
person yet right I was sitting in the
office answering phones and Howard walks
in I had prepared for it because I know
either you had never seen me but I had
never seen you in person before okay
only on television are you a huge fan a
huge fan yeah yeah but I was all
prepared not to get nervous I'd like
just like I listen to Tony Robbins tapes
I'd like visualised because I didn't
want get nervous because I know Tony
Robbins tells you how not to get nervous
in front of me you can like anchor
yourself and get real happy and then you
want ball right anyway so you listen to
some Tony Robbins I thought I was
already but I was so nervous when Howard
walked in I couldn't stop I just start I
had to smile paralyzed on my face and I
couldn't stop staring at Howard and I
knew is just we would it would upset him
I just couldn't stop looking at him
right so I don't know if Howard was like
sensing my nervousness but as he passes
me by he like he squeezes my shoulder a
real friendly squeeze and it sent this
like jolt through my body felt like an
electrical shock so Howard keeps walking
by me and wait a second listen to this
but you felt something in your shoulder
when I touch like electrical shock go
ahead so he's heading towards Gary's
office he turns back towards me he
starts smiling at me really gently and
he starts saying I was gonna wear of it
but I try to encourage the interns go
ahead he starts saying to me you're
going to learn a lot being an intern as
he's saying this he's like gazing at me
and he locks his eyes into my eyes and
he starts to staring at me with like the
most intense gaze I've ever experienced
my life it felt like he was like
penetrating my entire being it was just
a few seconds but so he's sitting there
staring at me our eyes are locked and he
begins to get all wavy now I don't know
if this is something that you do to
newcomers on the show or this is just
some sort of parlor trick but
I should explain my shoulder ever since
the encounter I had a ski accident
and I had to tell Kathy when I start the
internship I couldn't move my left
shoulder ever since the encounter I have
full range of moving on my shoulder let
me see you lift your shoulder and you
never can do that I have call my father
you call my doctor I've been I was in
like a chiropractor for two years trying
to get a movie again Robin but what do
you think of this go ahead go ahead
Benjie I really don't want to be
ridiculed people don't understand my
healing powers it's finally confirmed
I've been touching myself for years
please be quiet
don't disillusion the boy and go ahead I
don't want to be ridiculed but no go
ahead
I don't consider myself a religious
person but when Howard got all wavy I
really hesitate to say this but I saw
the Virgin Mary yeah that's what I saw
all right I see Mary was she hot I mean
no she was attractive you know I thought
you were staring at me kind of odd when
this happened this and I thought you
were just a little weird or something I
had no idea what was going on inside I
mean you didn't reveal it but you just
were just staring believe me I was
scared that people would if I told this
I don't know what's gonna happen why did
you come forward because I think it's
important not so much that you guys know
because I have a feeling you guys
already know about this but I think it's
important everyone else it's listening
knows what's going on in here
right all right right take it easy all
right Benji thank you very much thanks a
lot Robin there it is the story of Benji
[Music]
I'll tell you what we're gonna do in a
minute
I'm locked up all right lock that door
for you